voilà en même temps les nouveaux
responsables donc de m6 métropole tv
fait préparer très activement le
lancement des nouveaux programmes
voici en exclusivité le générique de la
nouvelle chaîne m6 tels que vous pourrez
le voir à partir de demain matin
les responsables de cette nouvelle
chaîne ont été désignés lundi dernier
par la cncl titulaire de la fréquence
occupé jusque là par telesis en cinq
jours ils ont dû mettre en place de quoi
assurer la continuité du programme
résultat une effervescence cette semaine
dans les studios de production ici on
assiste à la mise en boîte comme on dit
de la méga aventure une émission de jeu
sorte de réplique de chasse au trésor
juste derrière nous on est en train de
mettre quatre heures d'émission la
première ce matin une deuxième
actuellement il ya encore deux à faire
dès ce soir même effervescence pour
l'installation du plateau d'
informations vous seront diffusés les
trois journaux quotidiens et pour la
mise en place de la régie finale rue
bayard dans les locaux de rtl dès demain
la nouvelle sis devraient être au
rendez-vous mais peut-être pas dans sa
forme définitive
l'a6 évoluera nous partons donc pour un
marathon de treize heures par jour
pendant 10 ans à dire quarante sept
mille heures de programmes il faudra
attendre le passage au deuxième milliers
d'heures pour retrouver le régime de
croisière le régime d'altitude
évolution également dans la diffusion
actuellement 17 millions de français
peuvent recevoir la six il devrait être
33 millions en 1990
à